regarde une étoile filante faut que tu
fasses un voeu
c'est quoi ça
je sais pas les niveaux de monoxyde de
carbone provenant de ces astéroïdes sont
sans précédent
déployé une équipe de reconnaissance à
sap monsieur vous vous trompez soyez
paré pour une activité hostile nous
sommes confrontés à quelque chose que
nous n'avons jamais vu auparavant
h la ja sauve notre fils jada
armurerie est plus avancé que tout ce
qu'on a vu auparavant c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait causer notre l'avouer
libraires
on s'en va à
c'est chacun pour soi d'accord on n'a
nulle part où aller je dois le mettre en
sécurité
cet endroit est devenu un refuge depuis
que ça a commenté
n'a besoin de combattants on peut se
défendre
on va être une armée d'extraterrestres
tout le monde à l'abri
par terre ici
oa
l'unique moyen pour moi de vous
ressortir
est de me battre pour toi et ton avenir
si on
peut détruire toutes leurs harnais loca
qu
on a été attaquée et mon fils
l'or poussés
voilà la cavalerie
on renvoie ces monstres ils viennent et
on les fait payer pour ce qu'ils nous
ont pris
il ne s'agit plus d'une guerre mais d'un
anéantissement